-Welcome to the show.
-Thanks for having me.
-I feel like I know you.
I feel like I know you
far better than I know you
because I read you
all of the time.
You have known Donald Trump
for years.
You have covered him
back in his real estate days.
So I want to ask
about last night.
He talks a lot about unity.
And then, at the same time,
says very divisive things.
Do you think he's aware
of the contradictions
that exist when he speaks?
-No, I don't.
[ Laughter ]
And I could go into depth
about that if you'd like.
Look, I mean --
A, I don't think he knows,
and, B, I don't think he cares.
-Yes.
-One of the things that he did
during the campaign,
his particular talent
was seeming to take both sides
of an issue, sometimes
in the same sentence.
-Yeah.
-And so, last night,
you had the soaring rhetoric
at the very beginning.
A couple of people compared it
to like "Bohemian Rhapsody."
[ Laughter ]
It was like,
here is this part
and then here's that.
So, there was the chorus
of, sort of, unity
and soaring rhetoric
and then we got to immigration
and chain migration
as he talks about all the time
and limiting the number of
people who can to the country.
And that is where his
administration has rested,
is on those policies.
And he does not see an issue.
-You mentioned that thing
about not caring,
I think it is very unlikely.
And maybe you can confirm this.
Did he ever finish
his speaking anywhere
and has a moment of self-doubt?
Or like, "Oh, no, those two
don't make sense together."
-He might have moments
of self-doubt,
but they are not about
the things that you're thinking.
[ Laughter ]
He has moments of self-doubt
about, like, the visuals
or how the scene looked
or whether a particular line
sounded good
or he will test things out
with different people.
He's not thinking of it the way
you're thinking of it.
-Got it.
I'm starting to think he and I
don't think the same way
about anything.
-No. No. And I feel like
we arrived at that a while ago
when you were in
the same room with him
at the White House
Correspondents' Dinner.
-In 2011. Yeah.
-Sorry.
I can't get that out of my head.
-No, we had a different take
on that one, too.
[ Laughter ]
So I want to ask this.
Because you covered him
for so long,
it does seem like he likes you
at times,
and then at other times,
does not like you.
But you certainly
have a relationship with him
that provides you
a decent amount of access.
And it is true that he has
reached out to sort of criticize
your work at times and gone so
far as to sort of rate it?
-There was one incident
in particular
where I was in the oval office
last year,
and he was giving me a very hard
time about a number of stories.
And he kept saying something
to the effect of
"You never write fairly
about me."
And I reminded him of a story
I had done about Mar-a-Lago
that he had thanked me for,
which to be clear,
was not the goal of the story.
And then he said,
"Oh, that's right. I think
that was about an eight,"
or something like that.
And it was not --
that's not normally what
you hear in response, but, no,
I mean, look,
I've gotten the angry reaction.
I've gotten the sharpie notes
that an aide
will take a picture of
and send you.
And then I've gotten phone calls
thanking me for a certain story.
And from each moment
to the next,
it is like the other one
didn't happen.
-Yeah.
-It just starts all over.
-Because you've covered him for
so long in his real estate days
and know, I feel like,
how he used to behave
versus how he behaves now,
it does seem like he thought
this job would be easier.
Where do you think
that comes from?
-So I think a few things.
A, I don't think he thought
much about running,
what this job would entail
other than running for it.
-Yeah.
-I remember having
a conversation with someone
close to him during --
I think it was June, maybe,
of 2016.
And I said,
"Does he want to win, just win?
Is that it? Or does he actually
want to be president?"
And the person stopped and said,
"You know,
that's a really good question."
And I thought, that is indeed.
And I think that was the answer.
And, look, he would be pretty
candid that he didn't spend
a whole lot of time thinking
about it, he was superstitious.
But I also think that his view
of executive power
was formed in the 1980s.
And he's got this weird,
preserved-in-amber thing.
His cultural references are all
about, like, "Time" Magazine
and sort of movies
and celebrities
from a certain period of time.
And that was sort of 1980s
New York,
which was
a pretty corrupt city government
where he was
a real estate developer
where laws and regulations
existed to get around.
And these were obstacles
that you moved.
And that's, I think, what he
thought it was going to be like.
It was basically going to be
like mayor of the country.
That is not what it is.
-Turns out that's not how it is.
-It is much harder.
-What do you think
would bother him more?
Because he talks about
the fake news
and how he's unfairly treated
in the press.
What would bother him more,
a continuation of that,
or if no one ever wrote
another word about him?
-That.
-Yeah.
-There you go.
Not even a close call.
-And do you think
he's aware of that?
And do you think he has a fear
that a day will go by
where he's not the --
-Yes, yes, yes.
Even as President,
I still think he has that fear.
I had an ex-aide say to me
at one point that he can't go
more than a few days without
seeing his name in the news.
And you will see -- you know,
there is this thing he does.
He loves sitting
in the dining room
next to the oval office
or wherever he's tweeting from.
And he'll be watching
television, and he'll tweet.
And then he'll see the news
change.
And then he is suddenly
on the screen.
And he loves
that cause and effect.
So, yeah, he would -- he can't
exist without the media.
-That -- you know, again,
I also think it would be
pretty cool to be able to tweet
and make TV change.
Like, I don't begrudge him.
-You can't?
-No, it takes hours.
[ Laughter ]
But I -- So I get the
instantaneous feedback of it.
I guess I wish that
it was more controlled.
-For a different purpose.
-For a different purpose. Yeah.